So here we are talking about recapitulating the work done or na in reading of
the poem selections of this forum.
Um,
and it,
it,
it's,
it's a little difficult,
um,
sort of that of course,
I'm not going to tell you exactly what we have been talking about.
We have been reading from,
uh,
the work outside of the divine comedy.
We started with the Vita Nuova,
uh,
which we read.
This you recall is a visionary techs as a store of an education.
It's an autobiography.
And we tried to explore,
uh,
what those terms mean and how they interact with each other.
How does one term shed light on the other,
what does it mean to write an autobiography?
And then at the same time having an education,
the two converge,
of course in Dante's imagination,
uh,
you can only write an education.
I started your education if you have a sense of what your whole life is about,
if you have some,
some pattern of coherence and intelligibility that you can impose on and extract
from respectively,
uh,
this the sense of,
of your life.
But above all,
I was interested in,
uh,
in that,
partial because it's,
it's sort of inter inter,
it's truncated at the end as a sort of interruption,
deliberate interruption because,
uh,
what kind of preparation that gives us [inaudible] repeated that adventure.
Dante not rates in Devita Nuova,
uh,
is kind of add another operation of the divine,
the divine comedy.
Uh,
in many ways the two Texas really,
uh,
are implicating each other in the sense that Dante finishes the Vita Nuova stops
writing the written wolf.
That's the,
uh,
inconclusive,
the unfinished quality of the text so that he can go on writing the divine
comedy.
If you see what I'm saying,
the Villanova ends with the statement of a project of a project to come,
which therefore will be in a certain way the fulfillment of what is a only
hinted at in,
uh,
in,
in the Vietnam War.
So the two texts is our little loop.
One is preparing for the other,
the other one,
but then there's the divine comedy.
Turns out that we were reading the divine comedy last time.
Um,
did the in comedy itself has a soul to inconclusive quality about it.
Dante reaches,
uh,
and,
and experiences the beatific vision.
And yet he's text,
um,
succumbs to the enormity of the task of describing it.
And there were a number of reasons why we said Dante does that.
I mean,
what seems to an is at the feet at the level of the imagination turns out to be
a great triumph for Dante's own theology,
right?
Because it's in a measure in which that the poem ends it a kind of repeating the
salt of the,
with the admission of the possibility for Dante,
the poet's language to contain and therefore re fi circumscribe that which he
has seen,
right?
Uh,
he sorts of,
uh,
ending with this,
this,
this question mark,
this vision of our effigy as he says her own image in,
ah,
that's all that is left in that for him to recall,
which really means that,
uh,
in the refusal to pinpoint,
describe and define the so called beatific vision.
Some people can be very disappointed.
Why doesn't it tell us what he really saw?
Because that would be the statement valid for him.
He wants us at the end of the poem to adventure,
to take,
to take our own journey and make our own discoveries about that which remains
the essential point of the divine comedy as is the essential point of oh great
texts of our tradition and the encounter between the human and the divine.
That is the point of all the great ethics.
Whether this is in the form of the Aeneid where the hero is always uncertain
about what the oral,
the gods are telling him,
uncertain has,
how to decipher it.
And yet he nonetheless pursues a,
what he takes to be and miss makes mistakes.
And he is along the way.
Uh,
but when he takes to be God's will,
this is the,
the way he can live out his own sense of ethical imperative to himself,
to his people,
the refugees that are coming from Asia minor and going to told an unknown land
and the divine imperatives or whether it's going to be renaissance techs from,
from uh,
uh,
Spencer's fairy queen to task source to Milton whole two creatures who I send a
theological epic the idea he wants to,
to,
to show his readers his,
he has one reader in mind.
They younger period and this is who creatures from Dante had never read him.
He read in part and was very fascinated by what he read.
Who wants to educate one young man many years younger,
be Korean to the real and bitter truth of what the,
the uh,
the piggery and philosophy may be and the bitter truth,
the harsh truth,
it'll creatures things is that there is no such a thing that,
that ours are the Roman world is the say created world that the gods have fled.
That's the,
but that is a still in the mode of an eighties,
eighties.
It is still a theological concern because an implication of what I'm saying is
that it is in itself may be a way of addressing,
of course,
it's a way of addressing the question of God.
Uh,
the unknowability of God,
the distance of that maybe they're non existence of the gods.
The divine comedy from this point of view partakes of this extraordinary
tradition.
But he does it in a way which is remarkably different.
Dante does his theology in a way which is remarkably different from anything
else that's like an before him and in many ways after him.
So I think there is a mode of recapitulation.
This is what I have to,
I will have to,
uh,
briefly illustrate and give you the chance to ask more questions specifically
about the poem.
But some of these things that I think have said,
the whole poem moves toward this kind of theology are condensed in Canto 33 of
Paradise recapitulated right there.
Of course,
in fairness,
he goes on talking about issues of politics,
which is not that they are easy,
they are very complicated,
but in some ways they're rooted in Dante's,
on theology.
There is,
it's too easy to believe that it autism is politics,
is his theology always imbricated with one another.
In fact,
sometimes the best way to understand the theology is to talk about the politics.
And the best way to talk to understand the politics is to really talk about the
theology.
They are completely always implicating,
uh,
each other.
And in federal talks or the ethics and the,
and the politics,
purgatory talks about aesthetics and ethics above the possibility of
reconstructing the human.
They're a human beings.
So fraud,
the seem to be so incredibly sunk into the ditches of their own perversions of
our perversions.
How do you,
how do you so radical,
Dante's condemnation of the political realities of civil war people
cannibalizing each other and not at a metaphor that man is a wolf too,
man,
but literally they are doing this.
So how do you get out of it?
It's very difficult,
you know,
to,
to be sure to ostracize politics from the possibility of the human imagination.
And then at one point said,
well,
I still need this.
How are you going to make a persuasive case for your readers that they can for
you in this was the great challenge of,
of,
of Purgatorio.
And we saw the,
the,
the question of time,
the great problem of freedom that all of a sudden seem to surface in purgatory
with Keto suicide.
You remember with the debate about the soul,
the soul and uh,
and uh,
uh,
created in freedom and by an act of freedom of God's freedom to the attainment
of the freewill and,
and this extraordinary concern of freedom,
uh,
and therefore the possibilities of the moral alive.
Uh,
we came to the,
the,
the conclusion Flatonia with uh,
with,
with a garden,
the garden of Eden,
the plays of pleasures that plays were pressures are not them.
They in and of themselves.
And the question becomes now because that,
that is the sabbath,
that is the moment where are your,
you are pleasure can be seen as the crown of work.
That which crowds of correlational one's own labors and so on.
But that is also rooted in theology.
And then we ended up in paradise where we really talk directly because I think
that's really the substance of paradise,
the possibility of thinking of an aesthetic theology,
how art and theology hole and go hand in hand.
Because what joints them is the question of not just the question of say art
being the temptation,
ethical temptation.
But now the question of beauty is the mode of revelation of the divine.
And therefore the implication was,
and that's hope I have said that very clearly that art becomes a way to know
God.
They weighed Condo,
the divine.
So we are moving away from,
from traditional assumptions about what is the path to go and encounter God.
But it's really the discovery of the sacred.
It's a sacred going to be found some,
some Texas.
And Dante seems to have believed that at some point in a particular,
in the animation of nature,
is it going to be found in the love that you have for your,
for your beauty.
So you will be at research for your Dante or whatever.
Now he goes home thinking about this concerns,
uh,
and how everything that belongs to the world of art is the part of the path to
the divine.
So theology and the aesthetics not just as well.
Aesthetics is a way we make beautiful the,
the reality,
the theological content of Dante's faith.
Not just that,
but not just that.
It's no longer the question over and ornamentation.
That was a problem.
By the way.
We'll creatures,
we're at one point says,
I really write poetry because I want to make pleasant the bitter medicine that,
that,
that uh,
uh,
epicureus costs owner administrating through what?
The way he says that the gods have fled,
that the resource that you think is a sacredness in the cosmos.
That's two Beta two bear.
I'm going to say it nicely now.
That's really not.
So for Dante,
how are they the actual exercise of art?
It's an ascetic exercise.
You got to move through art to refine you think and you question all of the
things.
He's not just the end ornamentation,
ornamentation of being the word for cosmetics,
for beautifying that we should one history,
which he was saying.
So this will the concerns.
And we came to came to three,
three of paradise and I,
I maintained to you and they say,
wait a recapitulation.
I think I have said to you,
uh,
I hope that I have said it all to you.
Uh,
but I will gladly go over it and I hope that,
uh,
if you,
if you see more or,
or not quite haven't seen what I think,
I haven't been saying it to say that last chance as far as I go.
Uh,
in this public mode here,
the first thing that we do,
we understand about dentists.
Theology is the extraordinary rootedness of his theology in the human reality.
The Canto three,
three is the candle of the prayer.
And we'll talk more about the prayer as a mode of theologizing.
Why is it a special mode of the organizer?
But the first thing he is a prayer to the Virgin Mary.
That is to say a way of thinking about how the divine has entered the world of
history and they human flesh.
So there is not such a thing as an extraordinary that I think even talking about
the cosmology of Dante,
I try to hint tied to say,
look,
the physical world and the metaphysical world are all part of one universe.
They are two separate hemispheres and yet there is always a cross as a cosmos
that will connect them.
But we'll make them because that's the,
the irony of every customer.
So you know what I mean by Cosmo's who I said it comes from the letter,
the Greek letter,
he in Greek,
right?
That's a cas my next,
and they will have a cosmos.
You have a point of intersection of the two arms,
but that becomes also a point of fright.
Things come together and can be seen to come together,
but things also seem to be divergent,
seem to be going away from the charter.
Okay.
This is the cosmos of Dante is an extension of what he will say in the prayer to
the virgin,
the the,
the,
uh,
the human rootedness of the divine,
not dualities.
Okay.
That's really the primary item and this will conclude with the idea that with
the it makes it persuasive that what Dante sees and remembers at the end is our
fog,
which is clearly as a throwback to genesis.
Let us make man in our image and likeness.
That's what Dante,
we'll say police also means that we are in the world of images.
That dampness on journey ends in the world of images,
but in northern images as deceptive appearances only that which he saw that the
whole of Purgatorio is full off now has somehow the image,
probably because of that hour,
the shared quality of that image becomes the locals of the sacred itself becomes
not something that just hides but also reveals the divine.
And the second thing that I think that we have learned to understand about this
theology of Dante is freedom.
That the foundation of our panties own are the foundation of his beliefs as
natural.
It's theological beliefs is in freedom.
And we talked about the theological virtues as you recall,
the theological virtues,
faith,
hope and charity 24,
25 and six with the various examinations or dunk ago or so,
if you're a cold,
we're talking about the fact that,
uh,
Dante,
things of faith as an APP to freedom.
And that's not unusual for those who have any theological interest too,
to even find traces and,
and,
and implications of this kind of statement.
Faith is for Dante,
a way of knowing he connected with knowledge,
which is not a way in that we have a saying that,
you know,
faith intervenes with knowledge stops here by stop because someone who is
interested in his curiosity of knowing now,
I don't know,
I'll try hard.
Maybe tomorrow I will know.
I don't need any faith,
right?
If you really think about the relationship with knowledge and faith,
you can't say faith emerges at the boundary line of knowledge was that boundary
line is always shifting.
And that would imply the progressive reduction of uh,
Eh,
kind of receding and a diminishing fragments of the,
of,
uh,
the dimension of faith.
But Tanti saying by connecting university examination and the Promo faith is
that faith itself is a way of knowing.
I have faith and that means her,
I see the world in an entirely different way.
I can see myself disengaged from everything around me.
I can see that nothing really matters that are all the patterns and,
and parameters of reasons are going to be found.
One thing that's really so it's tight with freedom,
hope introduces the question of the future and you cannot have freedom without
the future.
We talked about this temporal issues.
You can only think about the possibility of a future if you believe that there
is a novelty.
If there is a freedom,
if you are in bondage,
you cannot really think of it but philological because I don't want to confuse
you at all.
You remember that all the three cantos when it literally woven with references
to exodus,
all three cantos.
And the story of exodus,
which is crucial to Dante's poetic figuration,
is the story of the freedom from a state of bond.
So this is the way we understand him,
but then he also knows that freedom can,
you only have to shift,
you know,
this is,
this is Luther,
of course a freedom and faith are one.
And the same thing when this attack,
you remember I mentioned this to you,
doesn't concern Dante.
The is the issue.
And so I would mention it for clarity.
They debate the two of them,
Luther and Erasmus over the idea of what freedom of the will means.
And they're really the baiting at texts written essentially earlier by one human
is by the name of Val.
And they disagree about what that text means.
And I,
Luther says,
what to harass you really are,
are interested in,
uh,
in,
in faith as a form of order.
Uh,
I'm interested in faith as a form of freedom because that frees me from all
loyalties.
It's madness about the sublime quality of the statement,
but you only have to shift that the ground a little bit and realize that three
of them could really become in this the source of atheists because atheism all
of a sudden becomes important because human beings don't want to be subjected to
anybody.
It's part of the project to say,
I am my own man.
I am my own woman.
I want to do exactly what I want.
I don't want to have any loyalties or acts accept,
uh,
anything that I don't even see.
I mean,
we can,
we can bear with their master,
you know,
that we see and maybe has a knife,
but someone that you know is a distant and remote and [inaudible] says that's
the peculiarity of this religious belief of mine,
which is really all about freedom,
including the freedom to deny the divinity.
This is extraordinary.
Never heard of in the history of,
as far as I know,
and I have a very limited knowledge,
believe me,
there's no rhetoric,
very limited knowledge,
but I've never seen anything like this.
Third Element about this theology is really there.
The great element of love to discover that the way to God,
yes,
it's hard.
There are many ways,
first of all to God,
there is a philosophical way of going through knowing that is the the linguistic
way through the language and the outcome to this issue in a moment that is
poetry.
There is the world of beauty that I see the language of the heart,
but primarily it is the path to the divine is laugh.
All right.
That in which to Dante and Dante understands.
I wasn't saying that lovely,
so mysterious,
but I know that deep down you are your young people.
Many of you said a couple of here younger,
much younger than I am,
but not really that young.
So they are not surprised by any of this,
but you know,
but I know that deep down I remember being young how you think about the mystery
of love.
Ah,
that really speaks to everybody's heart.
I wasn't leading it that way,
but it is really a full point that the principle of election,
which is so crucial to love and not be quite explained that it was meaning in a
theological way as possible.
I was already thinking about the statements that I was saw going to make today
about Dante's theology,
so this is,
these are some of the issues that Dante,
the other day yesterday,
the day before I was asked the question about one line in Dante that was very
actually it's if it was a very good question about that fact that Dante's
allowed to see the true that that the light is always the truth.
I was a very good question.
What does it mean to me?
It was so clear and I apologize
because you know I said,
well,
this is really the biblical idea in your light,
which notes will tell you in your life.
I see the light,
we see the light.
What does it mean in your light?
We see the light.
And what he thinks is that it's part of this mystery that if you are a mistake
and you think that the divine is wrapped in the kind of a transcendent darkness,
you know that's the language or that it is really all wrapped him impenetrable
light.
It's both the same but neither light has the peculiarity of never Layton.
You'll see the origin of the light and darkness has that peculiarity of never
letting you see the origin of the darkness when Dan for reaches.
But these are 33 and that's the meaning and your light.
I see.
We see the light.
Dante's is finally the origin of light.
That's the point.
So there are moments where his site can become so incredibly sharp and so
penetrating.
So look at all these ways,
the ways that the many ways in which we can take available to us.
And that seems that we are always stumbling.
I got something that in the long run you have to stop.
And yet if you have,
if you,
if you think that beauty is,
uh,
is a part which is part of love,
beauties is part of,
uh,
love is a hunger for beauty,
then you play tennis,
we'll say in the Florentine neoplatonism Lawrence.
Uh,
I don't know where he found it.
Probably in Palatinose.
Uh,
love is the hunger for beauty.
But all these are ways that Dante,
uh,
keeps opening for us are opening for us in our journey to the line.
And then there's the prayer,
which is the question of language that has also become one of the ways in which
I indicated that said,
it's theological,
uh,
theological route to the question of,
you know,
neurone that we speak out of and speaking a language is an allegory,
a parable of,
of,
of our desires,
right?
A parable,
what we lack,
we speak because we don't have,
that's a specific,
and we speak because we had the Sydney and we are pointing maybe without really
knowing to what we,
uh,
what we need.
It's always a question of need.
And that has always way of connecting language and desire.
We talked about that all the time.
That's one of the themes we discussed and then all of a sudden this was two or
three though I share,
I said to you,
look,
the language now changes
all of us.
First of all,
the prayer to the virgin is all about longing,
the state of longing but not languishing.
And there is a team,
a logical connection there somewhere,
which is not not going to get get into,
but there's a longing for the divine to show.
It's Bernard of Clairvaux the great mistake.
He who is the great seers opponent of Robillard appears on the scene and
therefore that you got over here the polemics,
which we haven't got time for the polemics between our Bellard and Bernard that
clearly behind his operation in Paradiso 33 they all are waiting for the divine
to show itself forth,
right?
And this language and yet this desire all of a sudden becomes a language of joy,
of enjoyment.
And that's such an extraordinary shift.
Why?
Because Dan understands
the problem with desire.
Of course we like to,
we know,
we always talking about how much,
how permanent we like to be in a state of permanent desires was that's what
makes us feel alive.
Young,
right?
Your desire,
you want something.
But it's true.
It's true.
It's part of the great power of desire in the language of his eye.
But if desire work without an object ever,
then desire becomes of the greatest absurdity and futility.
If we go around thinking that we're in a labyrinth of desires,
then really that is this a joke.
Desire becomes a jog.
So Dan p praises this idea of enjoyment,
the possibilities,
this sweetness that is still is in his heart.
This is how the he shoes.
And then finally,
this idea of prayer and I want to stop there.
Uh,
um,
stopped with the pushing of prey and then,
uh,
get,
get your questions.
Cause the whole poem,
I think from the perspective of Paradiso 33,
taking her to respect to with a view.
Not only that,
the fact that there,
there are references to,
uh,
the first words down to users in fair,
no one is a prayer,
right?
[inaudible]
says,
have mercy on me.
You never know whether you're a shade man.
He sees something that shape indistinct,
turns out to be virtual.
This with poetry that lends itself,
lend offers itself completely freely.
You know,
you can go to the library,
pick up a book at three act of someone's generosity.
There it is in terms to it and begins with a prayer.
And the poem ends with a prayer and then begins with a pre close the whole poem.
They real quality and nature of,
of language is to be a prayer,
a prayer,
implying that tension that we have all the time.
Todd,
what for Dante told what necessarily transcends us.
There is always a reality that is touched directory by the hand of God,
but he escaped the world of,
uh,
of,
of the human plans and human,
uh,
the human project.
This is what I think the whole poem is about.
Um,
and it's above all a poem addressed to the future,
addressed to us.
That is to say it's not a poem about the past.
Dante is the least nostalgic of poets.
It's so easy.
You know,
if you're ready,
a goal,
a goal ever,
and you tell your grandchildren,
you read Dante,
I thought that Dante is a nice little story about the Middle Ages.
We are all nostalgic about the Middle Ages.
Maybe some of you are here.
How are these guys,
how were they living in a world of absolute certainties,
right?
Dante,
the poet of openness,
the poet understands reason and and understands,
understands,
uh,
the,
the uh,
risk.
That's really what,
what,
what this poem is about.
The talking about the future,
that poem addressed with a number of apostrophes to readers and whenever you
read a poster,
which readers from beginning of inferno to roughly parodies or 10 every so often
Dante dresses,
as you remember.
Then I said at one point he stops.
He made this point.
What are this addresses to readers?
We can read it.
Whenever you have that kind of up to the 18th central,
you're always with novels.
Now,
my dear reader now,
my gentle reader there coaching you pretending that crops we either couldn't
care whether you read or not,
I don't think ultimately it doesn't really care whether we are reading
environment now who are you following the little ship of poetry,
the few of you and I think he means that who are not afraid or how uh,
how,
how rough the seas are,
right?
He could chicken shipwreck and all of that.
Of course you can read those,
those,
those apostrophes as a way of saying,
look,
I need your readers because if I have readers I'm constituting myself into an
offer.
Right?
Cause in Kinda measuring which their readers,
then I am the author,
I am,
I'm an author because I have,
I married because the poem has made me internal.
Of course there is that,
but what I think this is about is you are going to use my poem as the bolt with
which you can start your own journey.
That's the understanding of the future.
The poet,
Dante is a port to the future,
which he said,
we were saying there is a little bit of irony is I say this,
uh,
that Dante is not the port to the past.
His wealth deployed toward which we are going.
The Middle Ages may not be a time of the past,
maybe the Middle Ages in a different form.
We'll certainly,
we'll come back,
we'll probably come back in the future.
This is what Dante clearly things.
So let's go now with your questions.
I hope you have many and uh,
not many,
I mean few so that we can talk a little bit about this.
Yes.
Whoever wants to,
uh,
you came in late,
so I must say,
I must repeat this.
You have to sign and there is that beautiful young woman right there,
Maria Deripaska that adjective you forgive me,
but it's true.
But also,
uh,
and uh,
the other thing is you have to talk very closely to a microphone.
Right?
Okay.
Well I wanted to talk a little bit more about desire and I'm glad you brought
that up cause it's been on my mind the last couple of days.
I was just reading
Shakespeare is 147 sonnet yesterday in which he says desire is death.
And it struck me how different Dante is inception of desire is and that it's
something that he seems to want to stay in and relish and it's almost life to
him.
Um,
we started this course with the Vita Nuova and
I got so frustrated reading it cause I,
I pardon me was saying,
if you love this woman so much,
why don't you do something about it?
You know,
but it's like Dante,
no,
he wants to stay,
you know,
in this place of longing.
Longing is his life for him in some way.
Um,
and
so that seems to me something vitally important to understanding what the divine
comedy means.
And I wonder if you could just go back and talk a little bit about the courtly
love tradition,
how that might have influenced,
Dante is thinking about desire
and,
and
more specifically in a spiritual sense as to,
um,
Dante is theology,
how desire played a role in Dante,
his conception of,
of his relationship to God?
Yes.
Okay.
Um,
well good,
good.
I like the fact that you bring in,
I will take the points is that it can remember them,
but,
but also following up my own law in the logic.
I like the way you bring in,
uh,
Shakespeare's understanding of desire and that desire.
It's not that it's really death,
but ends in death.
I that desire leads you to death,
right?
That this is a kind of uh,
uh,
that is in many ways also,
a view largely shared by Dante in the sense,
but it's not only that come to this stop there in the sense that you have to
understand that there's such a thing has and metaphysics of desire.
I don't know if the term is new to you or not,
what could that possibly mean?
But we talk about what does it mean that,
but other than its metaphysics of desire,
some of you may be a little bit,
uh,
unusual.
It really means this,
that desire that they said dialectics to desire,
movement to desire that necessarily.
I want this today.
Then I won that,
that desire is inexhaustible.
That's what it means.
And,
and fraud point of view,
it's very important for all those like Augustan intern.
It's part of this restlessness of the heart as [inaudible] mentioned.
That's the theological understanding of this idea.
We call it metaphysical because it really wants the absolutes desire by
definition.
I want now this,
you know,
the smoking of a cigarette for a great novelists,
that Italian is a beginning of the last century,
uh,
was the,
the true emblem of desire ending in ashes,
but always like a Phoenix.
You can start over again,
et cetera.
This is,
but it really means that it always,
it will come to an ends either in death,
in nothingness.
Finally,
you renounce all this idea was just that,
that's the desire or some idea of the absolute of God.
That's really,
that's what we mean by the absolutely.
The,
this absolute,
uh,
tension that desire entails.
Now,
then you asked me to,
uh,
talk about the veto mover and the uneasiness you had.
I mean,
you express the [inaudible] another spectral that easiness.
I know a man of action,
like you students will philosophy as you are.
Uh,
then,
uh,
you,
you obviously have,
uh,
have the kind of,
I think that you're supposed to have that,
that is such a thing as a passivity of the,
of the state of dejection,
the sense of the mastery of love that throws the lover poet in.
He doesn't even understand what love is at this point.
That's what part of the education is.
He wants to know the story of the veto Nova is a story of a poet who knows.
He doesn't know Beatrice.
He calls a beauty is only because in when in the near [inaudible] of her,
he would feel beatitudes.
That's what he says,
you know,
so,
uh,
there's a kind of arbitrary list two names.
We don't care about that.
Now we,
we go on with your life.
So that it's this idea that he is,
uh,
the power of love,
the eject him.
It's not yet a virtual,
it's a passion and that word passion,
it really implies that we think that the passion is what makes us go.
But now careful distinction of the will that becomes paralyzed.
The desire to be discovered.
But the woman he loves,
you know,
it's very important for him that she says hi when they meet in the streets and
he,
she wouldn't say hi and so he goes home and this dejected one say and I'm
worthless,
et Cetera.
So that is,
he's explaining the kind of,
uh,
that sort of state of dejection that love can bring in all the passion of love
can bring into the mind.
The mind is,
is,
is clouded,
uh,
unable to think straight,
but that for him also sheds light on the way he understands poetry.
So because he waits for poetry,
he comes,
he's a sort of poured very romantic poet who does think that poetry entails
discipline.
Yeah.
You,
it's almost like somebody else says,
well,
it's almost going to the,
the office at 7:00 AM you sit down at a desk and key parrot and then maybe your
managed to come up with a great line.
He hopes for Romantically,
for poetry to come to them for inspiration to come to him.
And then he realizes that his understanding of love was as wrong as is of the
love.
Passion was as wrong as his understanding of poetry that you got to really get
down and do something about it.
When he understands it,
it's too late for him because Beatrice has died.
So now the poem,
the project of the divine comedy,
because she,
she may be,
he has a vision.
He sees her,
uh,
at the thought of,
of,
uh,
God's majesty says,
I want to go there and meet with her.
That's by action.
That's action.
We will agree that that really is quite a [inaudible] completely changed.
How does this understanding of love connect with,
uh,
the courtly love tradition?
Uh,
that is really not a difficult question.
In fact,
I will give you a little better verb bibliography that,
uh,
cs Lewis has written a very good book on,
the allegory of love,
a book written probably in the late fifties,
but last time I read it,
which was recently some 20 years ago,
it was still very good,
very powerful.
Um,
the idea is this a that,
and I'm really paraphrasing cs Lewis more or less,
I mean with a lot of gaps in my mind about the,
the,
the richness of the text.
Uh,
the clearly what we think of love today as a romantic understanding.
It's really a discovery of the Middle Ages.
And I have been talking about the fact that as you may all recall,
the Greeks didn't have this romantic understanding or the Romans didn't have
this understanding of love.
You know,
when you read Talas,
uh,
the passion for a woman is something,
you know,
that,
uh,
he's always,
a little uneasy about,
that's not what a virtuous men should be doing.
It's a weakness.
We will,
the weakness of the world.
He got,
you know,
it's advice.
What can you do?
We are fallible.
We are Romans.
But we are also occasionally a little fallible,
but they,
idea of romantic love comes with province or poets in the south of France.
Uh,
when you call core three love,
I would distinguish that.
That's,
that's all.
The only thing I would say about it,
you don't read the Cs Lewis,
uh,
who ends up with love and,
and the history of loving the in the,
in how changes that is right in the renaissance.
But I would distinguish between the two.
I would not use indiscriminately courtly love and medieval ideas of love.
A quarter love implies a formalization of love and,
and it goes back,
some of you are new or writing a paper on this,
uh,
on Andreas Capilano's,
the art of courtly love,
which is a way of setting rules,
setting rules for life in the perception that love is a
potentially disruptive experience.
And so let us make it into a joke.
That's the idea.
You know,
let us,
let us establish protocols and code,
um,
but by means of which the women and the men can really interact and tell each
other,
uh,
what,
what this is about.
How don't hope marriage,
because that's a serious business concerning property and wealth and status.
So we then the fairly close boundaries of the quarterly love tradition.
Then you can go on making certain assumptions about yourself,
about,
you can play Oh,
uh,
the,
the greatness of women.
The secret of loving,
you know,
there's,
there's a certain code.
Okay.
Um,
in the other forms of,
uh,
our quarterly love,
the,
or the suite,
the new style,
the way developed.
Another book that I could mention,
he was in Valencia v,
which is,
love something.
Kind of remember the title Maurice Valance say,
uh,
he also discusses the shifts between province,
our understanding of love and the sweet new style articulated by Dante and his
Coterie of,
uh,
of poet.
Okay.
That makes it a hope.
Yeah.
Thank you for,
um,
an extraordinary series of lectures.
I was curious about the ending and I wonder if you could comment on Dante is
views about the papacy.
I thought his choice of Bernard of Clairvaux was very curious,
um,
and throughout the divine comedy,
he previously was grumbling about a paper or people intervention over temporal
powers.
So I wondered if you could comment on that conclusion.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Very good.
Good.
Good,
good question.
Um,
a,
of course I didn't talk about it and I think that what you're really referring
to,
I don't know.
Uh,
but I think what you're referring to is the fact that,
uh,
Bernard of Clairvaux,
wrote a great book called considering own consideration,
which seems to be about contemporary of life.
You know,
he's a,
the great reformer of the Benedictine Movement,
Monastic Movement in,
uh,
in,
in France and the,
the so called Cistercian monasteries,
which became the centers of culture where they would copy,
they will do poetry,
they would write music.
Uh,
they would sing,
I mean,
the,
the odds that way we know them really originated with him,
but he wrote this thick sole consideration,
which actually in spite of the title,
because you didn't know that,
you know,
what the consideration is a step before you come to contemplation.
You know,
there are a number of reflection,
concentration,
and then contemplation.
He chooses to write on content or no on consideration.
He dedicates a book to this treatise to Pope Eugene the fourth,
who had been his disciple.
He had been at benedict with a French man who had been a benedictine monk with
him.
And it's,
it's,
this is probably one reason why damper chooses Bernard.
They're not the contemplative monk that reformer all of paradise is populated
with founders and great reformers,
founders of olders or Justinian in the law,
et cetera.
Right.
Francis Benedict Dominate Bernard.
I said,
so,
uh,
in spite of the fact that he's a contemplative,
Bernard did not hesitate to write a text for the spiritual edification of his
ex,
uh,
disciple Eugene,
the fourth who is now a po and he's a way or how the office of the shepherd of
the church can distract him from the loftier spiritual aimed and the wrong.
So it's really a sequence of arguments about what you should,
how should you administer your time so that you are never really going to lose
sight of what your,
uh,
your are to Amos heaven.
Um,
Dan dimensions in this text by the way,
in the letter that so many people not,
I go on a challenge in your authority over,
you know,
the,
the letter to Ken grant that that may be,
I have no,
not with you.
With my graduate students,
we have gone over.
Uh,
but to me that is actually the indication of the fact that he refers to,
uh,
to the,
to the treatise by Bernard that the authority of,
he is the author of that letter.
Now you see clearly another way in which I can understand your question is that
you see some kind of divergence,
some sorts of break.
On the one hand,
this kind of invective the mood of the invective in Dante can talking about
Peter Saint Peter in Paradiso 27.
I mean,
he,
he doesn't spare.
He looks back after the examination on,
on,
on faith.
He looks back and he starts attacking what is takes to be the use of patient.
My place,
my play.
Remember that incredibly,
uh,
moral voice at races.
Is that right at the very end and that you seem to be worried about the fact
that Dante seems to be so morally,
and when it comes about the pope's and then becomes mystical all of a sudden,
it's not really one of your concerns.
Uh,
it could be,
it could become one of your concerns and asking this question about at the end
of paradise story three,
he talks,
talks about a Bernard such a mystic,
and yet all over he's been talking about the paper say,
well,
if you were a war,
if we were interested in that,
I would say,
uh,
there is no divergence in Dante between the prophetic voice and the mystical
voice.
That is something,
even even those who read the Bible,
we're going saying,
well,
the profits were visionaries.
In a way it's true,
but in a way,
it's not true that province,
we're not visionaries.
That profits were readers of history that they don't need to have.
Danial gave her interpretation.
It's zeal has visions.
Isaiah doesn't have vision.
So it's,
you see what I'm saying?
Uh,
the,
there is no clear cut distinction between the prophetic and the mystical.
Certainly,
nor in Tantra,
the two belong together.
Okay.
So that's,
I don't know that I'm answering your concerns,
but I overheard the number of say rumblings.
So your question,
uh,
I'm trying to take care of them.
Is it a reconciliation with the pain?
No,
no,
not in the sense.
No.
Uh,
that to talk about,
uh,
even Bernard,
there's someone who understands how are oh way lane the,
the,
the all the office can be and he was obviously writing because he must be aware
of what has been happening and what was likely to happen if you don't have to,
to become a chronic worrier and the historian to do that.
You can imagine,
you know,
this can happen.
Ah,
no,
there is not that.
It's,
I think that Dante is judgment about history is always very clear til the very
end,
very clear.
Um,
history needs every form.
And of course he would say because he's one who believes in the sacral mentality
and presence of the self,
how the selfish culture,
before I start talking about that the world needs reforming.
Let me just begin here.
That would be a,
an intimate,
an obvious way to say it.
So I call it the language of presence in him.
This hands up,
I am present to my own self and therefore I have responsibilities towards my own
self.
Before I'd be hard to be kept.
I started using the megaphone and saying,
uh,
let's reform the,
the,
the world that probably if they were ever to calm and not this know that Utopian
thinker,
it will come only because so many people of goodwill and then women would,
will his saints,
he's Bi,
uh,
blessed.
The blessed souls that he meets are willing pools.
Do something about that.
No,
no.
Reconciliation,
a sense of finally things were becoming together.
I don't think actually I hold on to that.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm just thinking more about um,
desire and love and the fact that the will is what loves and the will always
contains some element of lack or desire it seems.
So even if it,
you know,
can attain plenitude,
it still seems that Dante and talking so much about the will and the will as
loving Dante says that love always has some element of lack.
It's not just luck,
there is plenitude but still there's always this restlessness.
And so the love at the end where there is plenitude,
it seems to be a completely transformed understanding of love,
that it's not possible to go to return from,
you know,
in the beatific if you have this plenitude you know,
is it possible to go back,
cause it does seem like it's a completely transformed understanding of love when
you have just the plenitude and not lack anymore.
So with that in mind,
um,
does,
is Dante ever able to attain this love because this love that does have pundit's
you'd seems like it should end in silence with no language and Dante does go
back and speak and he does.
Um,
he,
he is still,
he is a pilgrim and a poet.
And so does he really ever moved from the images to the essences and is the
uncertainty at the end?
Not just because we have to go on the journey ourself,
but because he is still on the journey.
Uh,
well the,
um,
I know you are,
you are really voicing a very delicate issue in the poem.
It's a very controversial issue.
Um,
uh,
because that also implies the status of the poem.
Are you understand what I'm saying?
In other words,
if you really think that Dante seen has had the big TV conversion and he has and
now he's writing the poem to tell us about it,
then you're really saying that the poem itself belongs to a higher level of
experience because it's written by someone who is in full procession of grace.
That's your point,
right?
That's it.
That's a very delicate point because I have not been teaching down to that way.
Right.
I have not where I to say this at the moment of recapitulation,
uh,
I probably would,
I have wasted your time all along or one little detail that I want to bring you
for your attention and then I will go to the more general problem.
When Dante Meets Beatrice in purgatory,
Victoria 31,
this is getting really to be a recapitulation.
Are you talking about everything in the poem now?
Maybe it's speed it trees in Pelotonia 30 and then in 31 and put the poster of
the 31,
Beatrice Forces Dante to go into a confessional,
you have to go on into an admission of who you are and has to be public.
CanNot say,
well you I know,
you know,
but you have to be Julie Ashamed.
There was only that way.
You can transcend whatever it is that you have within your Dante,
uh,
reluctantly agreed to do that.
And then Beatrice will say,
I want you to go through this so that another time,
the future tense when you will see,
we'll meet the siren.
I want you to be strong.
And this to me implies that's one of the many,
oh damn Percy's sa Casabella another aesthetic temptation.
One doesn't have to have the temptation to kill someone,
you know,
to really feel that one is out of fives,
fallen out of grace.
But this is,
he meets Cassela and he remembers how sweet was that,
that song he heard from Casa and that sweetness still resounds me.
No,
he,
Dante is writing is talking as a port.
He meets you listeners.
I grieve then and I grieve now.
I,
so there's a way in which states within the pilgrim don't really uh,
go on changing value the same implying that there's some kind of continuity
between pilgrimage and poetry writing.
And to me the writing of poetry is an extension of the pilgrimage.
Damn pill goes on saying,
I have had the beatific Fisher,
I am now I know what enjoyment means,
not just desire,
but I'm coming back to the earth and therefore I cannot come back to the earth.
Is anything less than a human being with one project,
that project to write a poem because I want to retrieve that joy and because I
want to share the joy.
So I have sat done.
Two things in my answer to you.
One talking about the question of the pilgrims' experience and the relationship
of the pilgrims experience to the writing of a poem.
But I've also said that the poem stands as a sign for us know hermeneutical
moment.
He,
Dante means it for us so that we can,
and his journey continues.
Okay.
That's my aunts.
Uh,
you don't have to agree with it because there are,
I know that is,
that is there are the people I have been fighting those people for a long time
in my life.
I don't want to go back to those fights,
but I think that this is my way of looking at it.
Okay.
I can give you more bibliography.
I would rather not actually tell you the truth.
I don't want to tell you about those people who are writing the other way.
No,
I have written about them though in my,
my box.
So,
um,
I was wondering if you'd talk a little bit more about how Dante views other
religions,
if like in particular Judaism,
um,
and if it sort of falls underneath his idea of religious freedom and that if you
have the freedom to become an atheist,
you also have the freedom to choose a different religion.
Um,
and if you've used Judaism and Christianity as sort of a continuity,
um,
both driving from the same basis or if he ascribes the idea of succession as
him,
that,
um,
Christianity has succeeded Judaism and invalidates it.
And for that reason,
we don't find from what I can remember,
any Jews in in paradise.
Oh,
yes.
You do.
Okay,
then that's,
that's fine.
Well,
well,
I have to correct you immediately because then maybe you rephrase today they're
there because you,
Barbara will rephrase the question.
When,
uh,
Dante goes on listing in the,
in the,
in the mystical rose,
we even told that Beatrice sits next to Rachel.
She's,
she's a way of elevating her and then he goes on describing all the other,
we talked at length about Solomon who is a Jew,
I think.
Right?
Was a chew right in the Bible.
Um,
we went home talking about Nathan.
Uh,
I tried to make light of it because I wanted to tell you that Dante,
so his whole name,
but it's Nathan the prophet of David and also in the harrowing of Hell,
which is in no for with Dante describes what happens to Jesus after his death.
You know,
what does he do?
He harrows hell,
he goes into,
well,
what is he doing?
And he goes there to take the Patriarchs and the women with Israel and take them
to heaven.
That's,
these are facts.
You want to change you your question or I can go on telling you more an
answering the real questions that you are,
you are racing,
they said the relationship between Christianity and Judaism and uh,
and the other religions.
You want me to talk about that?
I guess by having juice in paradise and having the figure of Christ come in and
collect the Patriarchs if he's trying to integrate Judaism and Christianity or
somehow find a way between the two.
Uh,
okay.
so you're interested especially,
uh,
about Dante sense of the relationship between Christianity and Judaism,
or you want me to also address the other issue of the way he looks at the Hindus
and the Muslims?
So,
so we talked about Dante,
the other religions.
In fact,
when I would talked about Dante's relationship with the sense of Christianity to
the other religions,
I'd never mentioned the Jews.
And probably that too,
you may have been a kind of glaring omission.
I it,
this guy is talking about the big,
the big religions.
What about the Matrix of the religions?
The,
the,
uh,
Judy's,
it's likely,
I occasionally thought maybe I should say something about that says no because
Dante doesn't talk about it.
And so I wouldn't,
um,
but antitrust talk when he has,
and he's not the only one.
Centuries before him,
they were talking a main,
like
a great theologian by the name of Bonaventure,
a professor of theology at University of Paris.
I mentioned that text I'm sure,
uh,
in,
in the year 1274,
which is also the year of his death.
He was invited to Paris.
He was teaching there,
but he was invited to deliver a number of lectures and he gives these lectures
and then he goes on talking about the other religions that religions,
he knows Hindu and a Muslim religion.
And it's an argument I mentioned that because it seems to me that Dante follows
Bonaventure fairly closely when in the Canto,
some Francis Canto 10,
the description of the that that the legend of Sam Francis,
Uhh,
Francis is said to have gone to the Salton to try to convert him and fails.
And then Dante also talks of,
uh,
the,
the Hindus with references to the Ganges when talking about justice,
Dante's talking about Europe.
But in between he alludes to the [inaudible],
he talks about the Persians and the Hindle,
the guy from the hint who is born on the river,
uh,
Hindus,
the Hindus.
Um,
so what is their conception there?
The critique,
they are talking as Christians and they're talking from the point of view of
Christianity.
And the position that Bonaventure we'll have and Nanterre think follows him,
uh,
is the following.
How does it,
how can be,
can they be distinguished?
What do they share?
They talk about what they share,
what do they have in common,
uh,
and the having carbon,
eh,
especially with the case of the Muslims,
the biblical,
the Jewish tradition.
Let me just look mince words here.
The Jewish tradition,
that's really the,
the,
the common matrix for him.
Um,
he also notices differences.
The,
for instance,
the physiology of the Hindus is one that presumes the diffusive ness of God in
all things.
Okay.
That's,
no,
I don't think that's something that unusual.
What does it imply?
Because then they come critical of it and then implies the difficulty of making
judgments about what's good and evil.
If God is everywhere you have through the sacrality of all things,
which is a great idea.
And yet,
you know,
there are some aspects of reality where you don't like to think that they are
all alike,
is a way in which this is pantheism and,
and,
and can become,
uh,
therefore,
can become,
can be critiqued as the lack of distinctions and hierarchies and ordering when
they come to the Muslims.
Since the Muslim religion is one that talks about the absolute,
uh,
impenetrability of the human mind,
cannot ever hope to understand the divine.
We are here at the mercy of God and we live only by the mercy of God.
We can not go on to and say,
well,
but I,
I live by reason and I die by reason and I can get to know God.
He says,
well,
there is a great distance between the human and the divine.
So that's the critique.
If this is true,
then we have nothing to then it's an absolute transcendence.
And theses Christianity's that which literally mediates between the two.
Because at transcendence and absolute transcendence of God,
the way the Muslims understand it,
but there is also a possibility of a mediation,
not total mediation,
the way the Hindus understand it,
but the mediation of the cross,
the mediation of incarnation.
This is the way Dante takes the other religions when it comes to the pagan
religion mom,
because they had the pagan religions for instance.
And Dante there for us very much.
Um,
the,
the pagan religions,
their original,
the Greeks,
the religion of the Romans.
And Dante follows very much,
uh,
some fantastic,
who is the one two talks at length about about this issue.
Uh,
and,
and that's the ambiguity.
There are our adumbration of the divine,
but at the same time they big can become also blasphemous idols of the infernal
powers.
So there's this way of really the smashing if you wish of the items when it
comes to Judaism,
which is really the,
the,
the question that,
that,
uh,
with which you started.
Actually,
I think that Dante is,
uh,
I talked about that.
I shouldn't say that.
I didn't talk about it.
Um,
you may recall that I made a point,
uh,
in,
at the beginning of,
uh,
the readings of the poem.
Maybe,
you know,
pat was not very,
didn't see,
didn't seem to be very important.
It was important to me.
Uh,
I,
I met an air,
I sort of went on talking a little bit at length about the question of birth.
You remember how there are some characters,
representations of cat characters and,
and Dante continued.
I could have said the same thing in the prayer to the Virgin Virgin mother,
daughter of your son.
Two birds,
two birds in one stone and half half align as it were.
All right.
The order of your son Nantais focuses on,
on birth.
And I did say,
I went on talking since it looks like this about Virgil then talks about the
birth of a franchise car.
Jack couldn't cancel checks,
uh,
Farinata and Canto 10 endlessly talks about this whole issue.
Uh,
and then I went on talking to decide God is concerned with birth is a
specifically Roman.
I said this is really a room insight into the importance.
It's really what distinguishes I uh,
the,
the Greek tragic understanding of birth.
Your children can really become a curse in,
in when you read the,
uh,
that's the by the,
for instance,
when you read the story of we depose which stations being half Greek,
uh,
so to incorporate,
and then I added after saying that this is a Roman concern because it's this
whole,
it's tied to the notion of foundation,
the room and idea that you can start things over and over again with the
foundations of cities and the birth being the language.
Nature becomes historical and therefore I potentially like all of you
potentially can change everything around you.
It's not true as someone at a round table the other night in my department who
was saying that you have no experience,
there are no events,
of course,
that experiences and events,
every birth is an event that's down to is understanding because he can change
history,
can change the future.
I have the making the statement that I'd say Roman idea and for Dante that she,
he's a Roman and he thinks of himself as a Roman.
Florence is the daughter of Rome.
And then I added that this is also a Jewish idea of creation.
That that's really what we have,
mainly that the great invention that we have in the Bible,
that the world was created.
And that Dante is connecting to ideas,
enrollment and the Jewish idea,
which are miraculously convergence.
Is this an act to have useful patient?
Uh,
cause that's really the,
the,
what I read in your question is that an appropriation?
It's culture.
I think that that's really what you do.
But you can say that about the Bible.
You read the Bible to say reading of history over 800 years of its composition.
It's a reading of events around them in the culture and valid.
And that's exactly what Dante does.
So,
uh,
how does he look at,
he thinks that the Jews are a guest is really saying they are not Christians,
but they believe in a Christ to come and that will save them.
Make.
This really means that there is an acknowledgement of the dignity and,
and uh,
and certainly the originality of that division.
I answered clearly.
Okay.
You may agree you minority,
but it's clear that we agree about that.
I was wondering if you could just brief
you on a much taller than a need and the microphone in the universe.
Great.
If you could discuss the presence of violence and all of these texts that we've
been reading.
I'm thinking particularly about the Vita Nuova and the depiction of violence in
these dream.
It's filled with passion and a very strange,
um,
representations of the color red and all as both a lost full color.
The fear of death in these depictions of love,
which reminds me of courtly love and this idea that,
um,
our passions are sort of
transcendental violent dreams and images that come to us.
But so that's one question of one.
But the other is the presence of violence and violent imagery and putter diesel.
I'm thinking particularly about Marsha's at the beginning and control one also,
um,
the implied moral violation of Picard and these continuous images that remind us
of human violence and passions,
violence.
And I wonder how they fit in with the final vision of trend,
of the beatitude and human love
that brings us right back to the,
the,
the relationship with the historical and,
uh,
and the sacred really saw the violence has,
a parody or most of the sacred,
and in many ways the alibi for the sacred,
a sacred this is to be understood,
is that which tries to redeem the violence.
And Dante,
you're absolutely right.
Never flinches from,
uh,
the understanding that the world of,
of history is an economy of,
of,
of this ongoing ongoing violence.
It's true.
Um,
he,
uh,
he even addresses you write it,
the human beings,
the Cato who kills himself or hoping that with this death he can bring an end to
the civil war in Rome between Caesar and Pompey or,
but then the violence that somewhere like,
because you absolutely,
uh,
how love and genders violence,
incredible things he's done that you have perversions.
It's,
you know,
just,
that I kill because I want to steal someone's shoes,
you know?
Uh,
but then there is a way in which I think I'm engaged more tragic understanding
of violence because it's sort of,
it's so mediated and so disguised as love.
Right?
I can love from [inaudible] Francesca and yet that in genders,
a lot of,
uh,
a lot of violence,
and that has gone through all the phases for this,
this sort of thinking.
Uh,
that'll thinking that maybe that's really what history is about.
It's all about violence and that any effort that redemption,
Christ's redemption of violence,
that's really what the whole story of,
of,
uh,
Christian salvation is about.
90 mentions that this is not a kind of an opinion than to mention it in an
inferno 33.
You remember with the story of Vogel Reno,
uh,
in the background of that scene of that,
that the famous cannibalizing that is the story of the children,
uh,
have been,
have been killed to his children.
Um,
and you know,
and that's always the,
the death of the innocent.
It's through the beginning,
you know,
what happened to the children and we can go on arguing,
but what about this?
This kids will have notice sponsor what Indo centers,
Dante says,
and then you're over here in the background.
And I think that Dante wants us to over here the experience of,
uh,
of,
of the cross that was meant to redeem or violence and they didn't seem to work.
So there's a way in which he thinks that violence has even to the notion and to
the god of violence,
even the redemption succumbs to that vision,
the idea of redemption loses in connection with the end in relation to violence.
So that that would be the way we can,
we can come to,
uh,
to transcend it.
And there are a number of other extensions.
Even when we read Dante will say,
when we read,
we seem to be such an innocuous bland operation that we're engaged in right in
the,
in the,
in the choir to the studies,
et Cetera.
Then we are still very polluting the integrity of attacks.
We still extract was still break up that unity.
We isolate the passage,
we make part of what we want,
what we wanted to signify.
Hermeneutics is linked.
Interpretation is linked to its experience of violence.
What gives,
okay,
so we agree there.
That was your question.
How does Dante get beyond that and somehow managed to arrive to a beatific
vision?
I think that what Dante's doing,
it's denouncing or forms of violence,
confessing to them,
admitting them,
dramatizing them.
It doesn't mean that he's espousing them or he shares them.
Okay.
The whole point of the divine comedy is to acknowledge that it lodge it violence
lodgers even in him and within him.
But he wants to move beyond it.
And that's the ascetic aspect of his text aesthetic in the sense that he's
literally climbing up the ladder of a transcending that which is holding him
back.
And I don't think that,
you know,
if you're looking for a way that does,
then he does he get away from it because that's really the,
the,
the other question,
has he ever get away?
Not In the measure in which he's human and wants to remain human open to these
temptations all the time.
Okay.
Oh,
please.
As a pilgrim who has become a senior citizen,
I have had a question throughout the entire course and having red hour back and
Thomas Bergen and Mary and others,
the question is not been the answer for me and I'm not sure you can either.
Uh,
the question is,
you know,
who,
who is Dante,
uh,
as we've been responding to these,
even responding to these questions here,
I've jotted down Newman,
man,
citizen exile lover,
how it pilgrim visionary theologian,
Saint Paul and Teresa have John of the Cross,
Bernard of Clairvaux had their visions and they became saints.
Is this man scene?
Uh,
well,
yeah,
I,
I'm taking it a little bit of time to,
uh,
to answer because I,
you must know,
I think you know that actually there are people who think that he should be
canonized.
You'll probably do not know that they would think that they should be canonized.
Actually,
it was actually interviewed once about soliciting my ideas.
I said,
I hope not post,
I want to teach him for what I think he is a poet,
a poet,
a man of extraordinary imagination who divine's our time.
That's what I think has power of the imagination and who understands that the
greatest call on him and known us is really the possibility of the encounter
with the divine.
I don't know.
I hate that if I were to make a movie about Dante have been,
I have been,
sometimes some people have been,
I have been mentioning it to people.
Actually the,
I will make him Ma,
uh,
I would make him into a rebellious type
who seems to understand everything that he touches.
But he also is a way and takes as he should from everything and transforms it.
So he has a vision from that point of view,
the vision of how the world is,
and not to make him,
Vince the world,
convince the world,
his world,
the world of the divine comedy.
It's,
it's an extraordinary invention,
but a saint,
I don't know what this other guys have done exactly the way to make them
deserving of sainthood.
Uh,
my baby,
I'll leave it there.
I don't know.
Thank you.
I think it's time.
Thank you so much for your great questions.
Thanks.
Okay.